voilà c'est le moment magique
le pince solaire voilà
je suis Arnaud je suis ingénieur et
boulanger et on a une particularité ici
c'est qu'on fait pas cuire une bonne
partie du pain grâce aux forces solaires
qui est derrière moi l'idée c'est de
concentrer les rayons du soleil dans le
four c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça
aussi un concentrateur solaire et donc
on a 11 mètres carrés de miroir réparti
en 69 petits miroirs quand il a un rayon
du soleil qui arrive comme là chaque
miroir vient pointer dans la partie
basse du four et le four lui c'est une
boîte isolée qui permet de monter en
température en fait et donc on peut
cuire avec ça du pain ou tout ce qu'on
voudrait cuire dans un four mais ici on
fait du pain et de la torréfaction alors
là on est dans le fournil
on n'a pas de pétrin mécanique on n'a
pas de chambre froide on essaie d'être
le plus sobre possible on essaye de
profiter au maximum du soleil disponible
au moment où on travaille et donc on
adapte vraiment tous les savoir-faire de
la boulangerie pour se donner le maximum
de flexibilité pour s'adapter à la météo
du jour alors regarde la météo agricole
parce que sur la météo agricole on a la
météo heure par heure là on est plutôt
dans les périodes où le temps est assez
changeant et effectivement on peut avoir
des surprises d'une journée sur l'autre
ici on a fait le choix d'être hybride
donc quand il fait beau on cuit au
solaire quand il fait pas beau on cuit
au feu de bois là aujourd'hui il y a des
artisans qui viennent apprendre ici et
qui viennent voir comment nous on
s'organise et ce qui permet aujourd'hui
en France d'être à une dizaine
d'artisans qui sont installés au solaire
donc là je vais la mettre en face du
soleil
une fois qu'on est en face du soleil
on règle on règle les ranger
et donc maintenant en fait la machine va
suivre le soleil toute la journée et on
va donc ce soir elle sera arrivée par
ici
encore là on a un gros voile mais quand
en plein soleil on attend 900 degrés au
point focal en fait donc 200 degrés
c'est beaucoup trop pour cuire du pain
mais après c'est rediffusé dans le four
quoi en fait donc il y a besoin d'une
heure de préchauffe et après une heure
par cuisson c'est ce qu'on compte
habituellement donc en hiver avec 4
heures de soleil on arrive à faire
110 120 kg de pain parce qu'il y a 38 kg
de pain par fournée et on était et ben
il y a juste à calculer mais en nous
dans le Nord on a des longues journées
en été et donc on peut on pourrait faire
jusqu'à 240 250 kg de pain moi les 6
premiers mois d'activité ici donc je
faisais essentiellement de la
boulangerie j'étais en 100% solaire et
donc c'est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
parfois en cuisine des fois c'était le
mercredi des fois c'était le vendredi et
on est organisé pour les pour que les
clients soient au courant de ça et ça je
peux en venir chercher leur pain ça
c'est la remorque de livraison les pins
sont livrés en vélo
jusqu'à Rouen en livres à des magasins
de producteurs la plupart et après on a
aussi des points de vente ou c'est des
particuliers qui viennent chercher les
pains dans des bacs j'ai besoin d'une
heure de soleil pour que le four monte
en température et après je m'assure
d'avoir au moins 15 minutes derrière une
fois que les pinceaux dans le four 15
minutes de soleil et si j'ai ça je sais
que mes pinces sont cuits peu importe si
il se met à pleuvoir neiger une
boulangerie solaire ressemble pas à une
boulangerie de quartier comme on le
connait ça c'est ça c'est clair si on
veut utiliser un fournisseur faut avoir
la place de le mettre mais un boulanger
pourrait très bien presque vouloir ne
rien changer à son activité enlever deux
places de parking et mettre un four
solaire sur son sur ça et utiliser le
four quand il en a envie et bah même si
il fait que 15% de ses fournies dans un
four comme celui-ci je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de boulanger aujourd'hui qui
aimeraient bien réduire même de 15%
leurs factures d'énergie nous on n'a pas
eu d'augmentation du prix de l'énergie
quasiment pas 200% solaire et
atteignable tu as dans certaines régions
c'est plus facile mais ça dépend de ton
modèle évidemment tu pourras pas cuire
tous les jours et pour ceux qui cuisent
tous les jours ils pourront pas viser au
100% solaire c'est pas possible ils
pourront au maximum faire ce qu'on fait
nous en ayant des jours fixes de
production qui sont dépendants de la
probabilité qu'il fasse beau donc nous
en Normandie on est à peu près 40% de
probabilité sur l'année donc si on
arrive à faire un tiers de pin solaire
c'est bien